so me as an architect and then
these teachers domoraud broca early for
example as an engineer
and we realized and I realized
that mathematica was indeed an
extremely privileged exchange platform
to allow different
different people
with different training different
different
specific interests in their research in
their work as researchers but who
precisely shares a common vision I
am currently assistant professor at
the national school
of architecture paris malaquais g I had
the first
the first relationship with mathematica  in
with on the occasion of a work that
had been commissioned from us by an institution
in this case the Pompidou Center for
a work of scenography where the challenge
was to solve certain problems
I would say of
architectural formalization from a
mathematical angle but  with applications
always a little
variable depending on the evolution of
my work so it starts again
and immediately after in 2004 when
I worked on my graduation diploma
in architecture so what led
to the title of dplg architect at the time when
I did  a work on the question of
surfaces on the problem of
surfaces in
contemporary architecture and this work is a
work entirely written within a
single mathematical notebook so that
was I would say the continuation of this
first experience is by  elsewhere
I tried to introduce more and more
often mathematica in teaching
in my teaching at the school
of architecture of paris malaquais
we realized that mathematics was
really a completely
privileged platform because  we can manipulate
extremely variable data and here
I try to work since the
sport issues are much more about
urban planning and urban issues
I also try
to encourage students  working
on mathematica to do
image analysis for different reasons
classical architecture software which
is geometric modeling software
which is very oriented towards
architectural applications already have,
as I would say as a language, already have
a whole bunch  concept of architecture which
are written inside software
very simple things a post beam
door window insulation
thickness of the wall finally a whole bunch of
things like that which are really very
oriented architecture is very practical
and within the framework of  education in
architecture I consider these
things precisely as too practical it does
not leave enough room for a
real
architectural experimentation both more formal
more + mathematized in certain cases
but also more conceptual and
precisely with mathematics ask what
seems interesting to me c  is that we can
explain to a student how to
draw a circle  the same as the one
he learned in high school with a
Cartesian equation we can do it with a
parametric equation but we can
also do it by assembling four
donut
arcs or two pieces of bezier curves
to make this same geometric figure
so we  has access to a wealth of
geometries to a variety I would say
of mathematical tools to which we do
not have access
in my opinion in a
normal geometric modeling software and the
third managed the third great
interest seems to me to be its format the
format  of mathematica the notebook
the interactivity which allows
the fact that we can do everything in it
we can write we can import
images we can I would not say that we can
send sms but almost we can we
can query databases on
internet especially now precisely
with the coupling between the notebook and
wolframalpha all these things
seem absolutely
essential to me and and opens opens
the sign  ment and opens in any case
gives students an opening
to a world of giving a world of
knowledge that is completely different
from what they were used to so far
so that's what we are also trying to
make students understand
c  is to remain relatively open in
relation to that and precisely mathematica
seems to us to be a platform that is quite
suitable or even very suitable
for exploring to have a
very exploratory approach